[Music]  I think they should get another Roseann  I thought you were dead  thank God think they brought Dan Connor  back he was dead right and they just  brought him back so why can't we get  another rose and there's other funny  women they could do that part  you need to couldn't get the comic in  there I hate to see a comic lose a job  Jerry Seinfeld speaking out on ABC  giving the green light to a Roseanne  spinoff enjoy while the comedian is  thrilled to see the Connors return to  the small screen he told ety star  Roseanne Barr shouldn't have been fired  after her racist tweets I didn't see why  it was necessary to fire her why would  you murder someone who was committing  suicide yeah that had to be but I never  saw somebody in the retired career with  one button voice that was fresh she's  finally coming out of her shell quiet  everybody  [Music]